- The White House's top
public health advisor
warns Georgia's governor against reopening
the economy too quickly.
Vice President Mike Pence
says the coronavirus epidemic
could be largely in
the past by early June.
Coronavirus deaths in nursing
and long-term care facilities top 10,000.
Hi, I'm Jason Bellini
with the latest reporting
on the coronavirus crisis
from The Wall Street Journal.
- I would advise him not to
just turn the switch on and go
because there is a danger of a rebound.
- [Jason] Dr. Anthony
Fauci cautions the governor
of Georgia against rolling
back restrictions too soon.
Republican governor, Brian Kemp,
announced earlier this week
that non-essential businesses,
including hair salons and gyms,
would be able to reopen as early as Friday
if they follow state social distancing
and sanitation guidelines.
President Trump also
criticized the governor
for moving too soon
but said that Kemp quote,
"Must do what he thinks is right."
Georgia is one of several states
that are starting to loosen restrictions
as jobless claims have hit
record numbers in recent weeks.
The House is expected to vote
on a nearly $500 billion
aid package today.
In an interview with The Journal,
Vice President Mike Pence voiced optimism
about the country's progress
in tackling the coronavirus
and said the nation is past the peak.
- [Mike] By early June,
we could be at a place where
this coronavirus epidemic
is largely in the past.
- [Jason] Though concerned
about the lethality
of the virus, Pence
the US will be prepared
if there is a second wave of infections,
pointing to new medicines.
A Wall Street Journal survey found
at least 10,700 fatalities
in nursing homes
and long-term care facilities.
Though some states haven't
reported data on deaths
in long-term care facilities,
the survey looked at more than 35 states.
Massachusetts, West Virginia and others
have been trying to increase testing
for older residents and staffers.
Meanwhile, two new reported deaths
in California, including a woman
who died in early February
suggest the first coronavirus
fatalities took place earlier
than health authorities believed,
raising big questions about the timeline
of the pandemic in the US.